he's no stranger to northern ireland
this was his 40th visit but this time
they were receiving him as king
[Music]
i think them shaking our hands would be
what we remember most it was very fun
and amazing like i won't forget this in
my whole life
she got to shake hands with the king and
stroked on the head so i'm never washing
her head again he said we had a lot of
those at home she is the star of the
show and she is loving the attention
they raised the royal standard on
hillsborough castle
where the first minister designate shin
fans michelle o'neill offered her
condolences
incredibly kind things that you said
well she played a great role here in
terms of reconciliation
so
it's the end of an era for sure
it's been a hectic schedule for the new
monarch
and the tension has shown
[Music]
but he had traveled here to reassure
people that he'd honor his mother's
commitment to peace
my mother felt deeply i know the
significance of the role she herself
played
in bringing together those whom history
had separated
and in extending a hand
to make possible the healing
of long-held hurts
may look like any other part of the
united kingdom people turning out in
number to welcome the new monarch but
there is still an underlying tension in
northern ireland so these people were
transported in by bus from a secure
location and no one got anywhere near
king charles without having been
security screened
in the hallowed silence of saint anne's
cathedral they gathered for a service of
reflection protestants and catholics
paying their respects to the queen in
the presence of the king
[Music]
prime minister liz trust sat alongside
her irish counterpart theishuk mihal
martin
although informal the king's short
meeting with ireland's president michael
d higgins was his first with another
head of state
[Music]
he said his mother had prayed for this
place and its people desiring the best
of times for them and for those here who
love the queen there are high
expectations of the king
you'll be a wonderful king
david blevins sky news in belfast